in the last video you saw how your death
and test then should come from the same
distribution but how long should they be
these guidelines the house set up your
dev intent says are changing in the deep
learning era let's take a look at some
best practices you might have heard of
the rule of thumb in machine learning of
taking all the data you have and using a
70/30 split into a trainee intensity or
if you had to set up train death anta
says maybe you would use a 60% training
and say 20% dev and 20% tests in earlier
errors of machine learning this was
pretty reasonable especially back when
data set sizes were just smaller so he
had you know 100 examples in total these
are 70 30 or 60 20 20 rule of thumb
would be pretty reasonable yet like a
thousand examples maybe you know yet
10,000 examples these heuristics are not
unreasonable but in the modern machine
learning error we're now used to working
with much larger data set sizes so let's
say you have a million training examples
it might be quite reasonable to set up
your data so that you have 98% in the
training set and 1% def and 1% test I'm
going to use dnt to revs:1025rpm deep
learning error where sometimes with much
larger data sets is quite reasonable to
use a much smaller than 20 or 30 percent
of your data for a def set or a test set
and because deep learning algorithms
have such a huge hunger for data I'm
seeing that the problems we have large
data sets that a much larger fraction of
it goes into the training set so how
about the test set remember the purpose
of your 10 set is that after you finish
developing a system the test set helps
you evaluate how great your final system
is the guideline is to set a test set to
be picking up to give high confidence in
the overall performance of your system
so unless you need to have a very
accurate measure of how well your final
system is performing maybe you don't
need millions and millions of examples
in your test set and maybe for your
application do you think that having
10,000 examples gives you enough
confidence in the final performance or
maybe 100,000 or whatever it is that
might be enough and this could be much
less than say 30 percent of your overall
data set depending on how much data you
have for some applications maybe you
don't need a high confidence in the
overall performance in the final system
maybe all you need is a train and death
set and I think not having a test set
might be ok in fact what sometimes
happened was people were talking about
using train test splits but what they
were actually doing was iterating on the
test set so rather than a test set what
they had was a train dev split and no
test set if you're actually tuning to
this set to this death schedule is
tested as better to call it just said
although I think in the history of
machine learning
not everyone has been completely clean
and completely rigorous about calling of
the death set when it really should be
treated as a test set but if all you
care about is having some data to train
on having something is attuned to and
you're just going to ship the final
system regardless and and not worry too
much about how was actually doing I need
to be healthy it's just called a trade
deficit and acknowledge the no test set
this is a
unusual I'm definitely not recommending
not having a test set when I'm building
a system I do find it reassuring
so the separate test set you can use to
get an unbiased estimate of how was
doing before you ship it but maybe in
the but it is a very large data set so
that you think you won't over fit the
deaths at too badly maybe it's not
totally unreasonable to just have a
train death set although it's not what I
usually recommend
so to summarize in the error Big Data I
think the old rule of thumb of a 70/30
split that no longer applies and the
trend has been to use more data for
training and less for death and test
especially when your very large dataset
and the real thumb is really to try to
set the death set big enough for its
purpose which is helps you evaluate
different ideas and pick a gap or a or b
better and the test set the purpose of
test set is to help you evaluate your
final classifiers you just have to set
your test set bigger now for that
purpose and that could be much less than
20% of your data so I hope that gives
some guidance and some suggestions on
how to set up your death and test sets
in the deep learning era next it turns
out that sometimes partway through a
machine learning problem you might want
to change your evaluation metric or
change your dev and test sets let's talk
about when you might want to do that